how'd you pick the puppy uh you know I
gonna let you in on the ocular
manipulation thing Dave and I just
picked the cutest possible puppy we had
to rob the eye instead of that love
later so yeah it was a bit manipulative
but uh Daisy was you know this little
beagle that was probably the cutest
thing with the big floppy ears we just
like what would be the most
heartbreaking animal on this planet to
demise yeah so witty
in a sense and beauty in love and
everything you could imagine personified
in this one creature and then some guy
we met on the matrix working with the
Rochelle Seas and in terms of influences
of the matrix in John wick I think
there's a lot I mean we both went in
house key film school yeah I think the
world building was something you can't
help like how to make action beautiful
how to expand worlds or create this
reality from the smallest prop to the
biggest set piece to lighting to the
fact that the action is a story the
story is the action it doesn't stop how
to continue through and develop your
character to do that like you get to
know neo by the way he fights not just
by the way he talks or stands or
anything that's a big part of his
character and I think that stayed with
us I mean there's so such influential
filmmakers and their attention to detail
and the depth of which they go the
meaning behind everything from the color
of the set to the Wardrobe to the way
the characters perform was it was I
think you're lensing in framing too
because wachowski were very influenced
by Japanese Hong Kong cinema Italian
cinema you know yeah the framing
composition the way we jump out and let
the let the camera tell a lot of the
story their editing style I think is
fairly symmetrical the wide thing
they're not trying to rush anything
they're trying to just let you witness
the story and experience it and suck you
into the world rather than rush you
through anything again I I think the
influences are pretty mess
like you know but you have your own
flavor now to wachowski light John wick
was a script that was originally written
by a gentleman named Derek Kolstad and
it was attached with a producer named
basil ironic at Thunder Road pictures
they sent me the script I read it I had
some notes they did a couple of drafts
we were looking for directors and I
spoke with basil about meeting with
chads2 he'll ski and David leach who
were action directors and who I had
worked with David and Chad on the matrix
basil had heard of them maybe might have
met you and what did you do well this is
interesting
he said that Keanu Reeves is attachment
oh we know Kerry yes we had met before
so they gave us the script to considered
like doing the action directing on it I
think we chatted real quick and said
well this is great but for the money in
time we didn't know if we could deliver
what they wanted kind of thing but then
we did talk to Keano and say well we do
have another idea
yeah said this is Dave and I are both
looking to direct we're looking for a
script and the original John Waite
script had this little humanist to the
assassin story you get this guy who
loses wife but she dies of natural
causes instead of being killed by the
bad guy the trigger to his action is the
death of his puppy and we thought wow
that in a way it was written it was
really simple it was really clean and it
was really like wow this is it felt
different the script that we had got so
we went back to Keano
literally I think the next day going you
know don't want to insult you anything
like that or mess up your career but we
were thinking like maybe this would be a
good one to direct and he just wants
yeah cool it was military that simple is
like okay well give us the weekend I
think was a Friday
monday we pitch to Keanu or idea of it
he's like cool and then we went
collectively and pitched to basil who
went cool and then we started the
started to develop it how much for the
car she's not for sale
oh I love dogs
Lucy was super clear it's right center
I want a soup in yet right so in terms
of the John wick world it's you know
started from the base of John wick you
know the world of the Continental in the
world of assassins and the world that
John wick takes us back into where we
meet Winston the manager of the
Continental and Lance Riddick is the
concierge of the Continental and then
you meet some the other characters
around that world so there's a lot there
and then once we the reaction of the two
the first film we had to then had the
opportunity to build up well what's next
I think in the first one it really
helped that we wanted to do a little bit
of a juxtaposition to your average
action movie so I think it was Kiana's
look I just lost my wife I really want
to play it very sad very realistic and
then you can see the trigger when the
assassins come and there's a little
knock on the door and the police officer
opens Jimmy and that was our whole
switch where the color palettes changed
the tone of the movie strange but I
don't think it would have worked as well
if we at least didn't tease the audience
with real-world how Keanu reacted to the
puppy how I did with his wife's funeral
and how somber that can make you seeing
in the toothbrush the closet and then
return with world Vince Jones Jones yeah
it was a tone that reality the hyper
reality I think once we switched into
hyper reality sky was the limit but I
think you had to start from somewhere
and really show the onset we get it but
now look we're gonna lift the curtain
and show you what can really happen just
a [ __ ] car just a [ __ ] dog just
I love live performances like he loves
sitting in Washington stage so like all
the action was kind of choreographed but
you can sit and watch again you know
everybody gives us a long takes the the
the limited editing stuff I mean we
certainly don't that's not like the
overall goal our goal is immersion and
the more you see Keanu doing stuff the
more you'll buy into that John wick is a
badass because you're seeing Camrys be a
badass it just goes with the immersion
into the character and to do something
like that just takes a lot of rehearsals
with the extras it takes a lot of
training time so that Keanu is top
manager and the camera operator has to
be everybody's got to be in sync if you
want to do those kind of things it just
takes a lot of practice and a lot of
rehearsals yeah because you did that
kind of I mean people would say that
it's a video game
first person shooter aspect but that's
only one thread of it I mean like you
said emergent also comes in with like an
in that in that sequence I think there's
a handoff right where younger time go in
Jim comes out and then it's you start
going you see them with one person then
you'd hand off to another person another
person who's off camera then deal with
them then there's another hand don't
feel like the maze aspect of it going
through yes thread a motion path and it
goes and you got to puts you in this
spot it's not quite first-person shooter
but it does give you that perspective
that you're with John a lot of times in
old gunfights so beyond the good guy
then they'll cut to the bad guy then
we'll go to the good guy and then they
go to the bad guy we just wanted to see
all the close-quarter stuff happen in so
we're really only showing you what we
want to show you and now because of
Technology and the effects so we can be
safer with blanks and firearms that we
can do close let's go to our stuff and
put the put the stuntman in that and
there used to be a blank you would have
material come out of the barrel now the
technologies they can just have an
explosion but the round will reject but
nothing will come out of the barrel I'm
much safer so we can do tighter stuff
and keep the frame the way we want to do
it
[Music]